faut savoir c'est qu'à trois zones à
protéger un le poignet le pouce et la
tête cd métacarpe
voici la dernière version du bandage de
protection des boxeurs un produit
fabriqué par la start plaisir oise band
axes des équipements utilisés par des
athlètes français comme tony yoka
estelle you came ou sli ou encore
sofiane oumiha ils seront aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo
tony yoka ça c'est faire via sa femme
estelle you came hausse mais avec qui
j'ai commencé à travailler il ya de ça
m'a quand elle est passé pro en fait
quand elle est passée pro elle avait
besoin justement d'avoir un cat man dans
son équipe et chercher à avoir une bonne
protection demain pour ses entraînements
elle est venue ici dans notre atelier
pour justement essayer de produits on a
travaillé avec elle
ça s'est très bien passé donc et ensuite
forcément j'ai été amené à rencontrer
tony qui importait du coup le bandage
dans sa deuxième version dans la
nouvelle version la version actuelle est
là aussi adhérer aux produits franck
romeo a créé bon taxes en 2010 cette
spécialiste dans la conception des
bandages de boxer il a voulu leur
faciliter la tâche
objectif protéger et faire gagner du
temps aux sportifs si des champions du
monde et des champions olympiques comme
tony hawk a comme lomachenko nous font
confiance pour protéger leur outil de
travail c'est que le produit répond
vraiment à une attente
en plus de travailler avec des sportifs
de renom en boxer en mma il a fournit
aussi les boxeurs de la team farrugia
d'elancourt comme marvin petit houga du
school ont la volonté de bandas que
c'est surtout de protéger les mains à
l'entraînement parce que c'est à
l'entraînement il ya beaucoup de
blessures c'est là où il ya la
répétition des coûts et ce à
l'entraînement que les blessures secret
pour cette société l'objectif à terme
est d'obtenir une homologation des
autorités de la boxe pour utiliser son
équipement en compétition